[Music]
if you are listening or watching this
that means we all
made it it's the day after the election
and we're all still breathing
for now today's show is about marriages
it's about surviving infidelity
surviving addiction it's about marrying
somebody that you love
but who's of a different religion and
your parents say no go
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what's up i'm john and this is the
dr john dolone show
where we take your calls about your life
your marriages your friendships
your communities what's going on in your
heart in your mind your mental health
all of it and we're helping each other
rethink
re-examine and reconsider our lives how
we talk to ourselves
how do we talk to our loved ones how we
talk to our pets
our neighbors people we disagree with
people we love
we're gonna talk about family issues
infidelity finding
love again we may talk about people
who wake up they wake up in the morning
they grab a cup of coffee then they
think to themselves
you know what i need i need my truck to
be louder
and then they go on the internets and
they scroll for places where they could
they say i've got a truck and it's huge
it just got to be louder and then they
find a guy
and they go to the muffler shop and they
look at the guy and they say i have a
perfectly
perfectly good truck it gets things
where they need to go
it gets me where i need to go but i need
it to be
louder i need everyone in the
neighborhood to know that i just backed
out of my driveway and put it in d
and went forward and the guy's gonna
look at you and be like hey this is
murica
i'll take your money why do you want it
to be louder and
you're just gonna be like you'll flex
and be like
cuz and he'll go all right dude by the
way cool mustache
i will make this thing louder for you
and i'll get it back to you as soon as
possible and i like your camouflage
pants
and so whatever we're going to talk
about all of it whatever's going on in
your home
your heart your head i'm here to stand
and walk with you
even those of you who drive loud trucks
i have camouflage paints too by the way
so if you're a camouflage pant wearing
person
don't send me cards and letters i'm with
you give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
that's three three two 1-844-693-3290
one you can email me at ask john ramsey
solutions.com
that's ask john ramseysolutions.com and
here's the thing
this podcast is going out the day after
the election so we might not even have a
world anymore
nobody may ever hear this except for the
cockroaches and the coyotes
and the few people who have been
prepping for years
if you guys hear this on a ham radio set
congratulations you all made it
we're proud of you you're um
what are you calling your shipping
crates that you buried under the ground
and you've got years of food stashed
outstanding way to go those of y'all who
read
uh cormac mccarthy's book the road and
thought that was a
or 1984 and thought that was a road map
that was a
a suggestion for how to live
congratulations you made it
um if we're still all around it's good
to see you
and i'm glad you're listening and
hopefully we can be making more shows
here all right so let's go to the phones
let's go to our first call let's talk to
gwen in omaha nebraska gwen good morning
good morning how are you
i am good um i'm calling because i've
been struggling with my husband's
infidelity and gambling for years
yeah and i'm just at a loss let's get
into it so
back me up and start me from the
beginning
um we got married in 1997
and have four kids and then in 2010 he
came home and said he was just
leaving and he was gonna go live with
another woman in a
another town and it was just over
and i didn't see any signs of this at
all
that i can even look back and see and
then
eventually he decided you know maybe we
shouldn't and we went to counseling
wait stop right there stop right there
so did you divorce him at that moment
did you say
fine you're out or did you hang in there
what what was going on your heart and
mind during
during this time i'm a fixer so i
was like well we need to do something
you know we have four young kids here
so i encouraged you know i was like well
maybe we need to go to counseling and
figure some stuff out so yeah no i
didn't
divorce him at that time and
we went to counseling until he decided
this was worthless
and he's different and he's changed and
everything will be fine
let's just move on and we're just going
to move on
and so i thought for a while it did
change but he has a huge
sports betting addiction as well i mean
he was ignoring us and the kids
mainly me and the kids and focused on
all of that
and then i got i was still so hurt
and really didn't ever work through that
because i wasn't allowed to
say that i was hurt why weren't you
allowed to say you were hurt
because he was changed it was done he
wasn't
doing that anymore he was a different
person ah
okay so just to recap here um and this
is a this is a common approach
um he you have four kids life is just
chaotic were they young kids
pretty close in age all under seven okay
so
you you have a hurricane
blizzard diarrhea bomb literally dropped
in the middle of your living room
and he decides i'm out i can't do this
i'm out of here
and he moves in with somebody else you
don't like that
nobody would like that but you don't
want to let that go and you think you
can heal him because you love him you
love him you love him
and you don't want to be stuck with four
kids by yourself so he
leaves her house moves back in with you
goes to counseling sees the light and no
one's ever allowed to talk
about what happened in the past now it's
all about moving forward and if you
bring up the past or
any sort of pain or past hurt you're the
bad guy right
yep okay so now we are
you're in a house where you've got four
kids that are a little bit older now
you've got somebody
who's sharing your house that you're not
fully healed from
who has his own addictions that he's
dealing with multiple addictions that
he's dealing with
and you now on top of all that are
silenced
yep your feelings don't matter and so
you went and did something dumb huh
yeah i had an affair okay so you have an
affair
and then how long does that affair last
oh it was like
it was a couple months maybe okay i mean
it was not
i saw a future with anybody else it was
just i was mad
and i just went the wrong way
sure but hey let's let's let's just call
it what it is
um it felt good for somebody to look at
you and desire you right oh definitely
okay definitely it felt good to be
wanted right
right wrong or different affairs aren't
good and all that but it felt good to be
wanted and desired to be heard
okay so then then
tell me what happens after that i
essentially got mad again and just told
him you know this is what i did and
i'm not happy and something needs to
change
and well then things went kind of
downhill from there
we just lived in the same house and
pretty much ignored each other and then
we went to counseling again until he
decided it was worthless
and went on our way i mean we just
pretty much have tolerated each other
and then
i got told out of the blue one day
get out i can't i can't deal with an
adulteress
called me a nice name and i can't do
this anymore and you need to get out and
i just can't deal with you anymore and
so
i packed up my stuff i moved my four
kids into
a home that had no furniture no internet
no beds
and my four kids came with me
only to find out a month after i've been
living in the shame because i
wrecked our marriage that he had a
long-term girlfriend
sure and he was going to move her into
our home
so if you kicked his butt out and moved
back in
um no i stayed away for six
eight months and lived by myself with
the kids and
it i just essentially i think i just
finally got to the point where i felt so
battered and just beaten down by
you we need to get back together i'm not
with her anymore we need to get back
together our kids need a
family our kids need a home life we
can't do this
you know apart and
you know after hearing that and then his
parents my parents
some of our friends were like you need
to give him another chance he has
changed he's different
and and in my i mean looking back i know
he hadn't changed
i i knew he was the same
person that he was 10 15 years ago
but i moved back into our house okay and
with our kids
and so now i'm sitting here going what
in the hell i'm so mad at myself
for going back to something that i know
i'm not happy in
sure and then i thought oh he had even
more affairs
after i moved back in then he told me
more it's like i keep on finding out
more and more and more and i never get
the whole truth
and i don't think i ever will right i
just i need to figure out how
how do i live like this because i don't
want to leave again
because what i mean the instability for
my kids i mean they're older
but i i just
i don't know i'm a loss so
it's a never-ending hamster wheel i feel
like you're right
and at some point an adult in this
relationship has to get off the wheel
and my hope is that your call today is
you
finally stepping off the wheel and when
you step off a hamster wheel that's
spinning real fast and it's been
spinning fast for a long time it's going
to hurt when you hit the ground you're
going to roll around for a while
and then you're going to get up and
you're going to dust yourself off and
you're going to have people in your
corner and then you're going to start
the journey of healing
but some one of the adults in this house
has to get off that wheel
and forget you two for a second you're
exactly right you are setting up these
kids they are they are absorbing every
second of this
so this is not a something to think
about in a few months from now
this is a house on fire emergency for
your children
okay this is a house on fire emergency
for your
sanity your soul you're worth more than
this
okay so
there's a lot here and you and i could
talk for the next three weeks
distill down here how can i help you
today
i just don't know how to
move out of this
hole i feel like i've dug myself into
without
completely destroying my kids okay
so let's i want to change some of your
language okay
did you have an affair once yep you did
okay
there's a period at the end of that
sentence you told them you were sorry
you told them that i wish i hadn't done
that and i'm gonna try to live
in a way that's going to redeem our
marriage from there
and that's all you can do at the end of
the day
continuing to beat yourself up and to
point back to to that being the
epicenter of the destruction of your
marriage
isn't honest it's not being truthful
okay so i want you to stop beating up
gwen
got it cool i try every day
i try every day i know i but now i'm
telling you okay
gwen versus gwyn is a battle that no
gwen's gonna win
and that was an awesome rhyme and if i
was a rapper i would probably uh write
that down
but i'm not um i want you to be nice to
gwen
number two do you want to stay married
to this guy
or no not really okay
say it with a conviction
yes i would like to stay married to him
no i do not
no i want to be treated better than what
i have been treated for 20 some years
you are still qualifying it do you want
to stay married to this man
yes no no i do not okay so
the next step is you will not move out
of that house
period your four kids deserve your
family home
if the person you are married to wants
to have a bunch of extramarital affairs
that's their business they're allowed to
do that
you my friend are worth more than that
your kids are worth more than that
everything about your ecosystem is worth
more than that
okay particularly your children
and so every time you every day you
avoid this conversation moving forward
this is going to be unfair what i'm
about to say to you but it's it's me
being as truthful
bare bones as i can every day you
postpone
contacting an attorney contacting a
couple of friends who are in your corner
not people who are going to tell you
what they want you to do
but folks who are going to support your
decision
every day forward i want you to say to
yourself i am choosing
to not be uncomfortable at the expense
of my kid's future
okay that's the that's the either or
decision you're making right now
and true there isn't going to be any
change that happens
you know that he knows that your kids
know that
everybody knows it we're just waiting
for an adult to hop off that wheel
and i never am in the business of
recommending somebody get divorced
but i am in the business of telling
folks if you have made a decision
you are torturing your kids you're
torturing yourself and you're torturing
him
by prolonging this
and if the story is exactly as you've
laid it out to me
he has been telling you for years he's
not interested in just having a
relationship with you
you have been communicating you're not
interested in having a relationship with
him somebody's got to call it
right and so if this is what you want to
do i want to encourage you to
stop stop the dot dot dot and just put a
period at the end of the sentence
and when you do it's going to hurt like
it's nothing you've ever felt before
and you're going to have to have people
in your corner who love you you're going
to have to have people around you again
people who support you
and it's gonna be a tough tough exhale
and then you're gonna be able to start
healing
and you are exactly right you are worth
somebody who treats you well
you're worth somebody who loves you
you're worth somebody who loves your
kids
you're worth somebody who doesn't cheat
on you over and over and over again
you're worth all of those things you're
worth your home being a haven of
rest you're worth a good night's sleep
but you gotta do the work
are you gwen worth that work
i believe so yes okay
do you have people who are in your
corner
i have a few then that's all i need
okay your parents don't get a vote
his parents don't get a vote he does he
does
sitting down and having a conversation's
fair but you're not moving out of that
house
you're not moving those four kids out of
that house you got it
agreed okay is there anything about your
relationship that makes you unsafe
physically
oh no okay i'm good
just emotionally okay that's about it
the only thing you can do at this point
is do the things that help you be well
and you probably have no idea what those
even are anymore
and i cannot recommend enough that you
go see a counselor
a professional in your area i don't care
if you can afford them or not
figure out a way to get that done sell
one of your kids you got four of them
right
um yeah don't sell your kids uh
someone's gonna send me a card and
letter about that
like i can't believe delony told him to
sell her kid don't do that but
um figure out a way and let them know
that after 20 years of being treated in
the following ways
after 20 years of multiple affairs 20
years of being kicked out of your own
home
for another woman to move in another
woman to move out all that
that you have made the personal decision
that enough is enough
and my kids deserve better and more
importantly i deserve better
and you want someone to walk alongside
you a professional to walk alongside you
as you go through hell which is where
you're headed
and as you begin to rebuild a beautiful
back half of your life
out of the ash okay
all right thank you are we on the same
are we on the same team
we are on the same team okay most
definitely gwen i love you
and i love your family i even love that
knuckleheaded husband who's
got all kinds of demons in his closet
and
i hope healing for you but that starts
with somebody
in your house hopefully you jumping off
that wheel
call me back let me know how things are
going in a month in two months and
don't hear don't don't miss any of this
it's gonna be
hard hard hard if this is the road that
you choose to take
but you are worth more than what you've
accepted and what you have allowed
your what you've what you've absorbed
over the last
20 years you're worth more than that
you're a beautiful soul miss gwen
in omaha nebraska you're a beautiful
soul
whew all right so this is the day after
the election
um chances are so i'm recording this
show a few weeks before the election
chances are there's not even a decision
maybe
but it seems like everybody's gearing up
for this thing to go for a long time
i lived through bush gore
and the galilee do the
like the the neutron bomb of diarrhea
that that was and that is my second
diarrhea reference of the show and i
don't even care
um so i'm hoping that's not the case i
hope there's a clear
answer this morning when we all woke up
um but there may not be
but here's the deal so it's a day after
the election
everybody's gonna exhale or everybody
woke up in the inhaled
but here's here's my rules for moving
forward and you didn't ask for him but
this is
you are listening to this podcast so you
can feel free to to click
off if you don't hear my rules but here
they are number one if you didn't vote
you are silent for the next four years
you don't get to play
you chose to sit on the sidelines and go
yeah get them get them but you didn't do
anything you never even got on the field
so for four years you have to just be
quiet you have to write poems and plant
gardens
and make your truck louder whatever the
thing is that you want to do
the if you did vote here's a couple of
choices you have
you can choose to gloat and be an idiot
and be like yeah we showed them
congratulations
we didn't show anybody anything you
voted your one vote
we all voted our one vote and your
candidate won
great we're all still on the same team
gloating is number one number two if
your candidate didn't win
you could take your ball and go home i'm
sad and i'm gonna pout and i'm gonna
throw a fit and i'm gonna demand this
and i'm going to
look that's not gonna solve any problems
either
you can take your ball and go home i
don't like our playing
but you voted you played and that means
we're all in it together
okay the third option which is i hope
everyone does is we can say all right
whoever won
won period i'm not going to fold my
business up i'm not going to pull all my
money out of the market i'm not going to
dump all my money back into the
i'm gonna choose to live locally which
is the only thing i can
i can do like i can actually get my
hands on the only people i can get my
arms around to hug
and to care for and i'm gonna work
really hard to make my local community
better and stronger
and more resilient i don't care which
side of the political aisle you're on in
this thing
we all know this is out of control and
we've all been in yelling fights before
or
fist fights before or kickboxing matches
before
where we feel it getting too hot and
it's hard to back out
what's the day after the election let's
everybody just stop
stop and look at the person driving next
to you right now look at the person
mowing their yard in the
the grass in the in the yard next to you
and recognize them as a husband
or a daughter or a father or a mother
as as the owner of a cat for god's sakes
right
the owner of a dog let's acknowledge him
as people and we have to figure this out
together
and a executive politician is not going
to solve
kindness issues it's not going to solve
basic humanity issues
it's not going to solve the bajillions
of trillions of dollars that we all
collectively owe
guys it's my freaking grandkids are
gonna have to figure out what to do with
that
it's my grandkids it's my children and
it
pisses me off enough with it
it's not our executive politicians are
going to solve our nutritional issues
and our movement issues and our mental
health challenges they're just not
that crap's going to get solved with us
and so it's the day after the election
everybody spit your mouthpieces out put
your gloves down
on the mats and let's look across the
arena the people we've been swinging
and kicking and punching and biting and
kneeing and elbowing and all of it and
let's just say
we're done same team same team
let's don't gloat let's don't pick up
our tennis rackets and go home
same team i want you to find somebody
that you have not been cool to that
you've been a jerk to that you've
ignored
a family member that you told off
halfway through the election cycle
i want you to call them today and say
hey i love you and i'm sorry
i want you to swear off any sort of
political nonsense for a couple of days
re-center i want you to send an email to
your boss and say hey i appreciate you
holding everything together
send an email to your co-workers or
handwritten letter your co-workers and
say hey thanks for
weathering this season with us we got a
lot of hard work to do let's go get it
done
no gloating no pouting guys we got to
solve this together
these are our kids these are our
grandkids
these are us let's go make it right okay
it's a day after the election
hope we still are all here i'm assuming
we are i hope the election's been
decided i don't know who won that's why
i'm doing this on the front end
but whatever happened let's work
together
let's work together all right let's go
to amy in new york city
amy what is up amy
hi dr d thank you so much for taking my
call thank you for calling i said your
name like five times i kind of made that
a little bit weird i'm sorry about that
so hey what's up how can i help
so basically my family is catholic
and my long-term boyfriend um well
technically my fiance
is muslim and but want to get married
sweet this is going to be an awesome
call
all right yes so uh
how can i help so he's your fiance he
asked you to marry him and you said yes
yeah and um i mean i i still haven't
told my family i don't know how to tell
them um i've already introduced them to
each other um
how did that go so in person
like they were like welcoming and
charming and this and that and then like
i visited them a couple days later and
they were like what the hell was that
what do you think you're doing yeah
bringing a muslim into this household
like we thought we raised you better
this and that
and to me i was just like totally
blindsided i had no idea that they would
react that way
yeah for sure so um
are you a practicing catholic or are you
more of a catholic
in practice in theory
i mean you're a theoretical catholic
okay yeah you know how to go up and down
and do all the stuff
in the service but you're right okay all
right and so is your fiance is he a
practicing muslim are you going to have
to convert
or is he in like like you are to
catholicism is
he that way to the muslim faith yeah
kind of i mean there's like there's no
pressure but
um i'm pretty sure once we like settle
down and have kids we'll probably raise
the muslim just because they don't
really
connect with catholicism like at all so
okay um but yeah like to me religion is
just like it doesn't matter
that much okay so why are you giving
your parents a vote why do you care
um it's not so much that i'm giving like
my my decision is made i'm gonna marry
him
but um at the time they were like giving
me this ultimatum of like you need to
choose like it's either us or him
um and i was trying to kind of take a
third route like hey i choose me
i choose what makes me happy and they've
like turned it around on me like
oh so you think you can't be happy
without us like
so here's the deal they put an ultimatum
on you but it's not really that
they gave the ultimatum and so
they said him or us and you chose him
and so that's going to be uncomfortable
and
frustrating and gnarly and heartbreaking
and sad and filling the blank fill in
the blank but that just
isn't his like how old are you
25 25 yeah you're you're a grown new
york woman
you're one of the most powerful people
on planet earth
i know some really extraordinary new
york women and they are awesome and they
are not to be reckoned with and they are
brilliant and smart
and kind and they know what they want
and
your parents gave you an ultimatum they
said him or us
and you chose him
so when i say it like that you don't
like that how come
it's just the whole situation it's
my whole life i've kind of been like the
image of like the perfect daughter
and i hate disappointing my parents um
and i don't
want the ultimatum to end up like with
me actually losing them
um like right now we're kind of at a
place of
like don't ask don't tell like i don't
tell them about him but they don't ask
me about him
yeah but that's that's you that's you
living into
that's you living this mirage that's
this fantasy amy
and in many ways you're becoming
you're you're diminishing your integrity
to be more blunt you're lying to your
family
and yeah in order to keep the peace
you're choosing to keep a massive part
of you the person you're going to spend
the rest of your life with you're
already talking about kids
how you're going to raise those kids um
you're being dishonest with them and so
what i don't want you to do is to take a
moment
that where they showed their cards they
showed who they were they showed their
character
our faith is
more important than you right so you're
going to be on board with our faith
you're not going to be with us and
you chose okay cool i call your bluff
but i don't want you to then show your
character
by then lying about it you made your
decision you made your decision
and the reality is you stood by your
values
and when we stand by our values it often
hurts it often costs us something
the sucky part about our current
ecosystem with social media is that we
feel like we live our values by thumbs
downing the crap out of something right
and we forget that when martin
dr king marched across the bridge he
thought he was going to die
but it was worth it to him right so
that's an extreme example of living your
values but
our values cost us something and in this
case
your parents they showed their values
our way
our faith or we're done with you
my guess is that they're not going to be
done with you
but you've always been the perfect
daughter they think that by leaning on
you in a heavy way
that you'll come back around and here's
the other thing i want to give them some
grace on this
and i know this is going to cost me
people are going to send me mean emails
and letters
um i believe it was pin or teller
it was one it was one of the the the
famous
um magicians in las vegas
um let's just say it was pen but i don't
remember which one
is a is a is a famous uh
atheist that the tall one james tall
yeah
really i've i've the the interviews i've
seen with him the things i've read he's
extraordinary he's a brilliant man
he's a kind thinker but he told a story
about
um he's a devout atheist too by the way
he told a story about meeting a guy
backstage
who was talking to him about what a
great show he had just seen
what a great magic show the guy was
talking about how impressed he was they
talked
shop about you know technique and things
like that and the guy said
hey i've just got to put it out there
i'm a christian
and i'd love for you to come to church
with me tomorrow here in vegas and um
i just want you to know i love you and
this devout
this atheist don't say devout but this
atheist said he was so touched and moved
because the guy wasn't trying to move
what wasn't trying to
um this wasn't a move he didn't hand him
a bunch of tracks he didn't wasn't
trying to beat him up with
he was just saying hey i love you and i
care about your future i care about your
soul
and i want you to know that you're
welcome to join me and what pen
said that stuck with me was when true
believers when true people
who stick by their faith and they
believe it to the core of their being
it's to them like somebody's in a street
in a truck is coming at him
and they pushed that person out of the
way to save him from that truck
and pin said i don't believe what that
guy was telling me
i don't i don't buy it but i really am
grateful that he saw me and thought i
was going to hit my truck and he he
thought enough of me to push me out of
the way
and so i tell you that story to tell you
this your parents
may be super devout catholics and in
their heart and mind
however right wrong misguided honest
true whatever word you want to put there
they believe that if you marry somebody
who's muslim your eternal soul is at
stake
the same as your fiance's family might
feel
that if him as a muslim marries a
christian he was to convert to
catholicism that his actual eternity
would be at stake
i would hope they would speak up i'd
hope they'd speak up in love
and i'd hope they'd speak up directly
and firmly and with care but i'd hope
they'd speak up because
they care that much about my eternal
soul
and then i hope they would continue to
love me and that's the decision
all people of faith have to make when
they speak up right
and so think of it this way that your
parents are trying to love you the best
they know how
they're trying to care for their baby
girl who's 25 right you're a grown-up
but in your eyes they're always going to
be seven
and they're always going to love you but
they're trying to love you the best they
can and they may just
be concerned for your eternal soul
however wrong you think that is however
goofy you think that is
and so in their way of trying to love
you they said it's either him or us you
chose him
and so just know that all you can
control is what you can control
you made your decision don't let your
integrity um
sag when it comes to protecting and
trying to keep the peace there
be honest with them be upfront with them
and tell them that you still desire a
relationship with them even though they
give that ultimatum and then you're
going to have to live by that decision
and that's going to be hard amy is that
fair
yeah definitely and so you love this
dude
absolutely he treats you right oh yeah
okay so i want you to remember that
moment remember
the values line that you drew somebody
said either or you chose you chose
or and now we're gonna all live with the
consequences
every one of us has values
is at some point going to be called on
the carpet myself included
myself included and people of faith who
reach out and say i'm terrified for x y
and z
thank them because they're they're
trying to shove you out of a truck they
see coming your way
even if you don't believe that truck's
coming
trust their hearts and their motives
behind that and
oh man and then people of faith speak
your heart speak your mind
and please please default to love
relationships and love
relationships and love all right um
let's see who's next here let's go to
marie oh let's stay in new york yeah
we'll go to marie in rochester new york
marie good morning how are you
i'm great how are you dr john so good
so good how can i help this morning
yeah well thanks for taking my call my
husband just
entered a rehab program for alcohol
how do i navigate his return home
wow okay man these have been a bunch of
just
light softball tosses of calls today man
this has been a fun it's been a fun show
so i'm gonna assume that there is a
trail of wreckage
in your home before your husband decided
to go to rehab is that fair
absolutely yeah okay well i could be
just we can just take a stroll together
through the wreckage and walk me through
it
sir yeah um so we've been married
for 14 years and
um i really started noticing
a lot of drinking that to me
wasn't really a normal type of behavior
um probably more so when our child was
born and he's nine now
okay um and it seemed to kind of go hand
in hand with some
stress from maybe being a new parent and
just some job
changes and things like that and it
really has gotten worse in the past
probably three or four years where he's
gone into a detox
program he's had a lot of counseling
and things like that
but this last time we really i i really
kind of gave him an ultimatum that it
had to be
either you need to go and get
actual treatment somewhere or you need
to leave because
all the pressure really has been on me
um and so you know schooling at home
um i'm the only one that works so he
hasn't worked since
um our child was about three
um so it's just been a lot of pressure
and
absolutely a lot of stress so i feel
like everything is on my shoulders
and i i'm not getting really a lot of
the support and help that i really need
just to run
day to day have you ever been in a
situation where
you're not safe no has he ever
i would say no as far as like he's made
he's done things that i feel would be
unsafe like
leaving the stove on unattended and
stuff like that but i've never been like
physically unsafe
um has he been faithful to you
yes okay um so
is this a is this a man that you love
deeply and you hurt for
or is this a man you are done with and
your ultimatum was
more of a bluff call
i i'm feeling more towards the latter
because i've just felt like i've just
been really hurt
and really struggling and i feel
so alone yeah absolutely um
how have give me some one or two things
you've tried to do over the years to
reconnect with him
five or six years of not working at all
just laying around drunk
and um how have you tried to bridge that
gap
or are you just busy trying to pay the
bills and make sure your your poor kids
fed and
etc yes how i kind of feel i feel like
i'm trying to get through the day every
single day okay
oh man so number one
this sucks and i wish there was another
way around it um
you've been living by yourself with with
two kids
basically for a long time yeah my guess
also is that your husband's got some
demons in his closets that are
real and gnarly and mean and ugly
and in for lack of better terms he's
been tortured for the last 10 years or
15 years does that excuse him not
working
no does that excuse addiction no
but it does provide a remarkable context
so my guess is
he's got some ugliness in his past is
that fair
i would say so i don't know of the
ugliness specifically
that which is really strange but okay he
has to have something
to explain this so
he i'm gonna be real honest with you
okay
as honest as i possibly can be so you
told him
it's either us or you're going to rehab
and you're getting well
and through his haze and
brokenness and disconnection he chose
you guys and he chose to go get well
and however misguided that is however
much you think this isn't going to work
and this is another attempt of
xyz um you left you put the cards on the
table and he said you're right and he
went
and the only way people i don't say only
way
it's very hard for folks to come out of
rehab all right let me back up
addiction is a disconnection issue
and when it stems from trauma when
addiction
comes out of the an addiction is just
your body's way of trying to take care
of itself it's trying to numb
hurt inside it's trying to cut wallpaper
over
fractured relationships disconnected
relationships
and it wallpapers over his fear and
alcohol does an
awesome job of literally shoving that
stuff back down under water it makes
that hurt go away
until it kills you right until it burns
everything around you
and the sucky part about chemical
addiction especially but all addiction
is that it shoves it all under water and
the one thing that can heal people which
is
connection it makes it hard and hard to
be connected right because the person's
an addict and they just
they end up becoming this this selfish
shell of themselves right
and so to tell somebody you got to go
get well
and then you're going to come home and
then to not be fully
into him and i say fully into him not
being fully on board with connecting
with him
is gonna be is gonna be torture for him
it's gonna be really hard his recovery
is gonna be his recovery and you can't
fix things for him
you can't make him go to meetings you
can't make him not cheat on you
you can't make him go get a job
but him doing these things to try to
help himself be well from the inside out
and then you still have in the back of
your mind i don't love you i don't want
to be with you
i don't want you in my house you disgust
me i'm
exhausted by this um he's going to feel
that disconnection and it's
really going to be a situation where
neither of you are going to end up
well out of this deal and so
you have to decide full stop when he
gets out
are you going to be able to move past
the last five years the last nine years
and um here's the here's the way i talk
about after infidelity it's a very
similar situation for you
you can't go back to 911 to the twin
towers we could never get all the dust
and twisted metal and glass and rebuild
those two towers as they were
they're gone but what we can do
is excavate the whole thing we had a
worldwide contest
to a worldwide competition for
architects and design
just savants to to redesign what this
thing was gonna
a new building was going to look like we
built a monument to what was
we acknowledged it but also we built a
brand new tower together
and that's what it's going to take for
you you're going to be all in and you're
going to have to be graceful you're
going to have to have a detailed
recovery plan of what
boundaries look like for you what you're
going to expect of him and
also you're not going to be able to just
beat him up throughout the entire
process right
remember when remember when remember
when it's going to have to be you guys
united moving forward
and if you're not ready to do that or
you don't want to do that
or you have thoughts in your head about
just him moving out and finally you're
free
and you want to see somebody else and
go on down another road
you owe it to yourself you owe it to him
you owe it to that nine-year-old
child in your house to make that call
now
so what do you think because i'm talking
yeah i mean
i i agree with you i mean i i
had mentioned marriage counseling in the
past uh
talking to your phone there always i'm
sorry i had mentioned
marriage counseling in the past but i
always felt this addiction needed to be
a thousand percent you cannot go to
marriage counseling if your person
if the person you're with is a drunk you
can't they've got to get the addiction
under control
no question no how and so what we're
talking about is
he's going to go to 30 days and let's
assume let's just go to fantasy world he
completes it with flying colors
he gets in there and about day of 15 16
he starts dealing with some old demons
and he starts he goes to group a couple
of times a day he starts to get
one-on-one counseling
he detoxes completely and he comes out
with a
with a recovery plan in his hand and he
comes with a plan to go to meetings
every
every day for 90 days he gets a sponsor
he starts the process
and are you at that point going to look
at him with his new clear eyes
and say there's my guy
let's let's go let's go rebuild
something magical together
or are you gonna go oh god here he is
again
right i need to see proof i need to see
a trap record
you know i need to see that i can trust
him okay i'm going to challenge you okay
all relationship all of the price of
loving somebody deeply
the the price of admission for love is
hurt it's pain
it's risk and so if he gets out
and you dangle love in front of him like
a carrot he's gonna collapse
you're gonna collapse
and i know that's hard and i know that
sets you up to be hurt yet again
but if you say if you do this
then i will slowly reveal myself
re-reveal myself to you
that is like starving somebody
especially an addict who's trying to get
well
[Music]
and so when he comes out accountability
means love
a recovery plan that you both agree to
that means love
i'm not saying he gets to come back in
and move back right back to the couch
and
or he's going to replace he's going to
start running marathons and still not
get a job and still not be present in
all those things
but i mean if you withhold love until he
shows up he will never show up
because that's not how addiction that's
not how healing works
you're gonna have to have some strong
boundaries
you're gonna have to have some um some
entrenched things that are gonna be
we are gonna live like this in this
house and then you're gonna have to go
be reckless with your love
you're gonna have to be willing to be
hurt again okay
and if you're not that is okay that's a
decision you made
but i don't want you to torture yourself
i don't want you to torture that little
nine-year-old and i don't want you to
torture this this guy coming out of
rehab
yeah but don't use your love don't use
your body don't use you
the essence of you as a carrot
you're gonna have to grab his hand when
he comes out and you have to walk
together
also remember in this deal the only
thing in the world and i say this over
and over and over again the only thing
you can control is you
and so you need to make sure this is
going to be a
wonderful time for you to
completely reimagine what life in your
home looks like
what does your wellness plan look like
what is your nutrition and workouts
look like what is your if you're a
person of faith what is
like re-establishing routines around
faith practices look like
um making sure you've got hobbies and
friends that you go see
and you've probably neglected all that
stuff for a decade now because you've
just been trying to survive
you know what i mean it's a disease of
isolation that's right
but it's a disease of isolation for both
parties right
yes and if you looked around my guess
is you can also become an addict
of planning an addict of lists
an addict of routine because that's how
you've chosen to survive this you've had
to survive it
this way but sometimes those are every
bit the addiction
that alcohol is it's a way that you numb
yourself
out it's the way that you don't feel
just so you can survive
and alcohol is the same thing and so
that's why i'm telling you i want you to
make sure you've done this for a decade
now
you've basically been a single parent
with a drunk living on your couch
and you're going to have to get well too
and you're going to have rage in you
that you haven't felt that you have
you have you have just stuff down there
as you had that's what you had to do to
survive and you're going to have
pain and loneliness that you have stuff
down you're gonna have to let
let that let out and that's why
the only person you can deal with on
this deal is you and so i
i please for your sake for that little
that little nine-year-old's sake for his
sake go get a counselor today
if you don't have one and start making a
plan together for when he gets out what
are your boundaries going to be
what are the what's it what's an
accountability plan going to look like
for the two of you what are the things
you need
and then how do you start like just
anchoring in
so that when he does come out you're not
going to hold him hostage with love
you're not going to hold him hostage
with intimacy physical intimacy
if you do these things then we'll sleep
together if you do these things then
we'll go on a date if you do these
things then i will
slowly let myself no you can't do that
once you set those boundaries once you
say you're welcome back in this home we
are all in this and we're going to
rebuild a new tower together for the
rest of our lives
and i think you can if he truly is puts
the addiction in his rearview mirror and
he does the things on a daily basis to
keep himself whole and well
man i've just seen it over and over you
can it's going gonna be hard but you can
but he's gonna need full you and you can
only have full you if you've got a
community if you've got your own
physical and mental wellness you're
prioritizing you're putting on your
oxygen mask first
you and that nine-year-old are spending
close quality time together not survival
time but close quality time together
and then whoo then the sky's the limit
and it can be a beautiful thing
but if you're out you got to be out if
you are
out you got to be out
so when you hang up on this call your
first call is to a counselor
set up an appointment and say here's
where i'm at and i need a professional
start walking with me
i am so grateful grateful grateful for
this call
and there's so many people whose
husbands and wives head off to rehab
whose husbands and wives
they have hard conversations they have
clearing the debt
conversations and then they start over
the next day and then they don't nobody
knows what to do right it's like all
right we're gonna
step up tomorrow and then tomorrow
happens so good for you marie
for calling i appreciate the call and
either be all in or all out
and either way you're gonna need
somebody to walk with you all right
that's the end of the show here
so for the the first podcast after the
election the first podcast for the rest
of our lives
i thought what's what's the greatest
song of all time
the song that you know people are like
that's my favorite that's my greatest
cool and then they're like nah that's
the greatest no that's the greatest
and then
in 2002 out of nowhere
you know out of the mouth of babes i
don't know how the end of that quote
goes but i'm just going to say out of
the mouth of babes comes tons of wisdom
how about that is that how that quote
ends i don't think so
but sometimes we go to old people we go
to wise people
accomplish people for wisdom and we
forget the 13 year olds
the 14 year olds and in 2002
on the extraordinary award-winning album
just simply titled
let go a 14 year old
or 13 year old i don't know 12 i don't
remember
12 year olds from canada
with the interesting beautiful name of
avril lavigne showed up
and she redefined what love is for a
whole generation of us
we thought love was romeo and juliet we
thought love was titanic
but no in her extraordinary song
a song so cool there was a number in the
title
avril writes in her legendary classic
skater boy she says he was a boy
and she was a girl can i make it any
more obvious
no avril you can't he was a punk and she
did ballet what more can i say
i don't think anything avril he wanted
her she'd never tell
secretly she wanted him as well and get
this folks but all of her friends they
stuck up their nose they had a problem
with his baggy clothes
her friends he was a skater boy and she
said see you later boy
he wasn't good enough for her she had a
pretty face but her head was up in space
she need to come
back down to earth now get this five
years from now she sits at home
feeding the baby she's all alone
she turns on tv guess who she sees
skater boy rocking up mtv ladies and
gentlemen
let everybody out there here just
because they've got baggy clothes
doesn't mean
that you can't love them too ah avril
thanks for giving us wisdom
this has been the dr john deloney show
you